Millennials will soon be the largest
generation in America's electorate with
potentially dictums dramatic effects on
the political landscape we're teaming up
this week with digital media company
refinery29 to explore the impact of
millennial women on the upcoming midterm
elections as part of our my vote series
we polled women across the country with
a focus on those issues between the ages
of 18 and 35 34 percent identified as
Democrats 27 percent as independents and
19 percent as Republicans the remaining
20 percent aren't sure of how they
identified politically we found that
seven in 10 are dissatisfied or angry
about the Trump presidency and the
direction the country is headed in but
only 30 percent of them say they will
definitely vote in November
with us now our refinery29 chief content
officer Amy Emmerich and CBS News
elections and surveys director Anthony
salvano great to see you both so I don't
like this statistic at all Amy young
women are the least likely to vote in
November why is that well that's the
goal is for us to use media and change
that right but I mean I believe I think
that the activism isn't necessarily
translating into the poll and one of the
reasons is in volunteerism and the
activism in the protesting we've seen
that's an experiential movement they can
feel the change they don't believe that
their vote matters right now they don't
trust the process they believe it's all
about politics and not about the policy
so why would you vote in something that
you necessarily don't believe in when
you can get out on the street and feel
the impact that you can make and yet
they're so invested in these policies
and making change specifically when it
comes to health care
why is health care such an important
issue for millennial women going into
the midterms well traditionally women
cared more about the health care in the
household right they did more doctor
visits with their kids they did more
doctor visits with their parents and as
women we have a long-standing
relationship with our gynecologists
starting at the age of 13 so we actually
go to the doctor more than men and
through that we see the discrepancies in
the system so they're much more focused
and they can see the issues and the
process at large you know it's
interesting Anthony the repercussions of
the 2014 midterm elections are such that
people now understand your vote
matter what is it specifically about
these younger women that they choose not
to but what reasons that they give well
look for many years we have seen young
people less likely to say that they're
going to vote you know part of that is
just as you grow older you start to see
how politics affects your life right or
you put down roots you buy a house you
have kids you start to see how policies
affect you so part of that is typical
but we also see here that further folks
the young women who say that they are
going to vote the motivation is really
high we find enthusiasm to be really
high we say that they think they think
that it matters who controls Congress as
opposed to the folks who say that they
are not going to vote and they say that
it doesn't matter who controls Commerce
so there are big differences there but
the motivation among those who do say
they're engaged is really really high
Amy what about actual participation in
terms of running for office we found
that a quarter of Republican women in
this age group say that women in office
would make things worse what explains
that well there's also the positive side
of that which they 50 percent thought
that it would be better to have women
more women in office right when you
combine the Democrats and the
Republicans I think when you look at the
Republican number there's something
behind this idea of feminism in this
belief that more women in office equals
feminism and what is their definition of
feminism and the study kind of showed us
that the Republican belief is that
feminism is where we blame men right
issues whereas the Democrat idea of
feminism is much more about equality and
I think that there's something to that
nuance that's leaning I wonder how much
the Clinton candidacy enshrined that
sort of part is a difference around
feminism and femininity Anthony yet
we've seen differences in this poll and
in others where we asked would you vote
for a man or woman if you had the choice
and Democrats are more likely to say
that they would pick the woman over the
man Republicans much less so and the
reason that they give when we ask them
is they think it would add diversity and
that's something that we have seen
Democrats respond to much more than
Republican voters who also by the way
overall tend to be older and not
necessarily part of this this generation
we're focusing on it's interesting
because every day we talk about how
polarized our society is right now but
among
lineal women at least 26 for only 26%
said that parties affiliation mattered
to them when it came to their candidate
of choice
are they being honest or we think
something different here we are seeing
something different and this is
something that defines this generation
not only are more of them saying that
they're independent but we also see that
as they get older they're not picking a
party
sometimes as folks get older they start
they pick one or the other this
generation is not and that's something
that is really defining for our folks
not be a bad thing for cultural
identification as much more than
anything else their self identifying in
a much more complex way in an
intersectional way than any other
generation before so you've got to
understand they care about culture and
values much more than they care about
party affiliate need to get out and vote
politicians need to figure out how to
get them out yeah it's a fascinating
sequence American voter Anthony
southmont oh and Amy Emmerich thank you
guys both